preguntarle en primer lugar a qué
atribuye no esta alta tasa de decesos en
perú
obedece pues que el pp dice una crisis
histórica sanidades de 50 años y eso
paga factura junto que el enfoque
básicamente es y hospitalario y el
enfoque comunitario es el que no se ha
enfrentado desde hace semanas el colegio
médico yo soy vicedecano el colegio
médico
ha participado activamente en
sugerencias del estado en el control
comunitario con pruebas con aislamiento
etcétera no funcionaba en gran parte de
perú y se explica la alta
morbimortalidad
ahora ha trascendido que existiría un
subregistro en perú y que las víctimas
mortales podrían ser más de 60.000 es
esto así usted maneja esta información
no es al control creo que hemos sido
sincerando en estos semanas y meses y
las cifras que tenemos es porque mente
lo que ustedes tienen tal vez faltarán
unos cuantos ajustes pero es la realidad
digamos sin exagerar que sea ciencia en
las últimas semanas por lo tanto
enfrentamos consecuencias del sistema el
sistema atrasado en todos los temas
igual que en américa latina que no se
salvan ni siquiera países desarrollados
y este económico pues paga factura como
decíamos de nantes y tenemos que
insistir en el enfoque comunitario que
es vital para contener esta enfermedad
que es como una maratón que no termina
prontamente señor marín ya trascendió
también que hay una alta demanda de
oxígeno en perú que estarían instalando
también plantas en los próximos meses
cómo están manejando estas
situación cuál es el escenario en este
sentido bueno la oferta con la demanda
el oxígeno sea dos veces pago factura en
la amazonía en el oriente peruano que
fue una causa importante de mortalidad y
gran parte del perú hacia afectado pero
felizmente la empresa privada del estado
está dotando de en estas semanas
abasteciendo un abastecimiento incluso
en los municipios que permite por lo
menos estabilizar uno de los problemas
graves que es el oxígeno dado que no hay
hoy día pues medicinas en el mundo y la
vacuna que ojalá salga pronto tiene más
una esperanza para el mundo tampoco no
es fácil para países pobres siempre se
queda en los países ricos no ojalá que
la vacuna se reparta bien en la torta
del anti kobe creo que es la demanda que
hacemos y creo que es injusto que la
vacuna no solamente se quede pues en los
países poderosos y los ensayos van a
permitir ver que la genética sirva para
diferenciar qué es resistente o no la
vacuna soy optimista en ese sentido pero
es una lista en el tiempo